first of all I have a special surprise
for you
so one of my best friends is a former
student of yours ally Meixner oh my
goodness and a lot of people know you as
TV star and headline Abby Lee and what
they don't realize is that you have
trained some of the best dancers in the
world and you're legit like your girls
go on and boys and become huge huge
stars so a thank you that me a message
for you a gorgeous stunning girl isn't
that amazing it's amazing so how are you
feeling how are you doing a nice
recovery you've been very very very yes
yes it's day by day hour by hour I'm
going to physical therapy in Pittsburgh
Pennsylvania at a great place and I have
great doctors there and they're working
right right now we're kind of at a
plateau I'm walking I can do stuff one
change with parallel bars yeah or with
the Walker but my right knee I've needed
any replacement for seven years and I
continuously say one more season yeah 13
more episodes another special another
spin-off and I keep putting it off and
now it's impacting my ability to walk
because when I take a step with my right
but I'm fine I'm great
but then when I try to lock out my right
leg to take a step with my left I just
crumble Wow yeah why was it so important
for you to be so open and show the
pictures of your scars and talk about
your hair and all of these different
things well I just feel that women today
don't really take care of themselves
they might get Botox and their nails
done and their hair done but when it
comes to their health I think they take
care of their children first sure they
take care of their husbands when they're
sick and they might feel in a pain or an
eight
see a spot or something it's nothing
you know oh wait a couple months see it
but see what happens and you can't yeah
you know I had a pain in the back of my
neck and it was literally ten days ten
days and I was in the hospital of
fighting for my life are you hopeful
that you'll be up dancing chasing the
little ones again yes absolutely
kidding and you know what's weird is
when I was away for an extended vacation
in Victorville California I was dancing
all the time and my friends would say or
people that lived near me would say oh
my god you're always dancing stop it I
didn't even realize I was doing it
because I kind of lost the joy of dance
and I had lost a lot of weight you know
it's all I do Pittsburgh is gave it back
but I had lost a lot of weight and I was
dancing I used to do a ballet bar at my
locker I used to stand at my locker and
do like a whole bar and I'd like to get
back to that I was excited to get on
prison and like set the world on fire
and be up dancing and moving yeah you
know and I felt so much better and
healthier and then this happened skate
ups and downs of life yes how did the
other women in prison react to you
coming and had they been fans did they
was it weird to be a celebrity it's just
like any other place that I go
some people love me some people hated me
you know I made some friends what I
should say I met women that are so
wonderful and so kind and so generous
you know one lady the car the redneck
Amazon Barbie
her name was gypsy she took the shoes
off of her feet and gave him to me she
had saved up her money from working in a
prison for months and months and months
to order her you know Nike whatever
you're allowed to order yeah and she
ordered them she had them a week and I
got there and they didn't have any for
me I had to wear the big black combat
boots that rip up your feet and your
ankles and she said here take these
there isn't a mother on the cast of
Dance Moms that would have given me the
shoes off their feet Wow
but you know when you need a favor ask a
stranger there are some other
celebrities that have gotten themselves
in a bit of trouble Felicity and Laura
Lachlan any advice to them what would
you offer them
lots of advice don't hire prison
consultant that's why be open with
people they are celebrities people know
them from TV TVs a big deal in prison a
big deal people watch it non-stop so
they're gonna be interested in what it
was like to be on a TV show you know
what's it like to married to John Stamos
you know on TV what are all these things
like they're gonna want to know they're
interesting I think if they share their
stories and their tales of woe and all
that that they will be just fine
and I also think it's important to
listen to listen to every other woman's
story because everybody there just wants
to tell their own story and be heard I
think that's what I learn most
everybody's there because of some you
know crazy nonsense stupid mistakes that
we make and their attorney said don't
say anything
you can't talk no we're not gonna put
you on the stand no no no and now
they're in prison and they still are
just trying to tell their story what's
the hardest thing what's the worst thing
that you would prepare them for the
guards really yeah there's bad it's
really bad
do you think those are the female guards
in the mouth whoa you know you you don't
need a lot of credentials to be a prison
guard in a federal prison and you know
you give him a set of keys and a weapon
and they're in power do you think
they're harder on people that are have
notary in my particular situation they
were because of my characterization on
Harrison and what I'm known for and you
know screaming at the kids and yelling
at the moms so everybody wants to have
their chance to get a baseball bat and
smack me in the face with it that's
that's what it was like I don't think
Felicity and Lori are gonna hit that
same thing because that's not the
persona that they have it's an Becky
she's America's Sweetheart exactly so I
think she's still going to be that how
do you think that your time in prison
and then coming out and then having to
deal with all of this and this cancer
battle have changed you well I'm not
walking and I went from being a very
independent person I mean my parents
were very mindful when they raised me to
be independent they were older when they
had me 38 back then
sure and they didn't know how long
they'd be around so I was an only child
but I was very independent I travel a
lot I did things I started my
competition team exchange of 14 I was
running a business building a building
at 22 so I think I've become dependent
on people that's how it is but I've
learned to say thank you and to say
please and to be appreciative you know
even when I'm in a department store and
I can't reach a hanger or rack I'm
dependent upon strangers and the
kindness of other people so I think that
that has changed me I was finished
considered the ALDC do you think that
the moms of the dance moms on this new
season are gonna think that they can
one-up you now that you've been through
hell and back no because they're coming
into it different and I think that's the
biggest change in dynamics on the show
is you're having people come in and
they've watched me in their living rooms
they've watched the television show
these kids this particular group of kids
watch the show 24/7 when we get on the
bus and we're driving to the competition
yeah I hear my voice behind me and I'm
like what is that and Gianna looks at me
rolls our eyes and she's there that are
watching constantly that's all they do
so they've studied yeah and they know
what my pet peeves are they know it's
gonna bother me and what's not so when
the moms kind of come into the situation
and I start to speak they kind of go
like they listen it's like I'm on
television they're watching me so it's a
little bit different
oh do you think that this is a different
group of people or do you think that
Abby Lee is mellow well I think the
audience is going to think of knowledge
no it might just be well at that
talented kid Oh move over and this is a
people don't I I've always said that
people don't change
circumstances situations change but
people are what they are your genetic
makeup is what it is so I'm thankful I'm
blessed I'm appreciative and grateful
for the opportunities I've had
and I didn't maybe think so before but
now after coming close to death's door
I appreciate life a little bit more
right like I'm five percent nicer yes I
like the imagery of this season Game of
Thrones
yes you're over done it's actually been
nearly two years since we had a new
season of Dance Moms so what can people
expect the dancing is incredible yeah I
want to get a split screen and I want to
go back and do some old numbers but kids
these kids crazy there's some good
really yeah we're not I'm gonna be nice
on a whole they're better and you know I
learned my lesson of course I'm not
gonna have one star I'm gonna have seven
stars just like when Ali was dancing
elegance with a bunch of had four blond
girls that were gorgeous girls that were
stunning she's absolutely exquisite this
young lady were talking about and they
were all good
and one day Ali would win in the next
weekend somebody else would winner and
next weekend somebody else would we can
share it wasn't that domination of one
girl one girl one girl one girls how are
you managing this new busy schedule
new season of Dance Moms and taking care
of yourself okay that is a great
question because that's been an issue
today I would have therapy in Pittsburgh
tomorrow I have it as well but I'm
flying back and with the time change it
just doesn't work right
so I have had to skip and cancel many
many appointments for rehabilitation and
that's not helping my case right are you
100% cancer-free then yes absolutely
I was cancer-free three chemo treatments
in after the third one I left Cedars and
went and had my own PET scan done and
there wasn't one solid cancer dr. puro
became my oncologist he's a brilliant
brilliant man and there's no chance that
it will come back this isn't the type of
lymphoma that does that this is Burkitt
lymphoma it's usually found in ten year
old or under little boys in Africa go
figure
Amy Abby Lee I am gonna just stick up
for you for a minute people like you
it's very hard to be in show business
and so people that Judge you and say oh
well you're so hard and you're so mean
to be you're just preparing people
the real world because then you get into
the real world and everyone's really
mean to so I appreciate you I think
you're God Oh congratulations on your
success and I'm so happy for you and
like your friend and like look at the
kids that we're on the show it's real
stars I know I mean it's crazy they
don't Jojo the phone and call their
dance teacher but Jojo does she does
yeah of course yes I was at her birthday
party and everything
wait when North West was there yeah I
need to go dancing school those kids
need to come to me right all those kids
we could do celebrity dance moms Kim
kardashian-west all the children
including nous somme yeah baby some
would like that's a dancing school oh
he's ready
yeah missing
[Music]